a lot can change in 10 years and a lot
has changed since 2009
in October of that year gearbox Studios
released Borderlands by combining the
progression of Diablo with the
satisfaction of a first-person shooter
it established the loot shooter as a
viable genre it set the stage for
staples like destiny the division and
warframe to break on to the scene
Borderlands 2 made its predecessor look
like a mere proof-of-concept the sequel
took everything that made the first game
great and amplified it fleshing out
characters weapons and progression
systems to add longevity to a proven
formula looking back on the hundreds of
hours I spent with Maya Salvador and
crew I still remember thinking how could
someone possibly improve on this which
brings us to Borderlands 3 I have had to
use a cliche a roller coaster experience
with this game in its early hours I was
critical Borderlands 3 opens with a
whimper front-loading its most boring
environments and my least favorite NPCs
he also didn't help that in the seven
years since Borderlands 2 my
appreciation for gearboxes humor has
significantly waned
suffice it to say I was apprehensive
moving forward by the time I reached
Eden 6 the fourth planet in Borderlands
threes larger galaxy I was disappointed
the formula felt dated it felt as if
gearbox had run out of ideas opting to
keep the great wheel spinning rather
than try to reinvent it because of this
it was still fun don't get me wrong but
some of my favorite games this year from
Metro Exodus to Gears 5 have drastically
questioned their status quo they chose
to reshape what didn't technically need
reshaping I was hoping with its
seven-year gap that gearbox might
somehow do the same I finished
Borderlands 3s campaign and resigned
myself to the fact that it hadn't but
then I kept playing and all of a sudden
over the course of the next two hours it
all came into focus
despite its garish color palette and
kaleidoscopic display of explosions
Borderlands 3 is very much a slow burn
it's only in its later hours the
hallowed endgame that it shows its true
work and now I'm absolutely hooked
there are various threads you can follow
once you've beaten the campaign the most
obvious is true vault hunter mode a
carryover from Borderlands 2 that allows
you to restart the story at your current
rank essentially its Borderlands threes
new game+ you could also try
slaughterhouse 3000 a wave defense mode
that will undoubtedly help you reach the
level 50 cap and improve your Guardian
rank speaking of which Guardian rank
acts as a second layer of character
progression replacing the badass ranks
of Borderlands 2 you'll earn Guardian
ranks at a fairly steady pace allowing
you to upgrade traits such as grenade
damage or fight for your life survival
time but while true vault hunter
Guardian ranks and the slaughterhouse
all do reward you for your time its
Borderlands threes new endgame options
that really make it shine my personal
favorite is mayhem mode essentially this
allows you to 100% the campaign while
also improving your character this means
you can finish those side quests you
miss or grab all of those collectables
you've previously ignored without
wasting your time
mayhem upscales all of these objectives
giving you commensurate loot and
experience points for your character as
someone who spent dozens of hours
mopping a Borderlands two side quests
that were dozens of ranks below in my
character level I love this most of
Borderlands threes best missions are
outside of the main narrative and mayhem
is an elegant way to reward players
hesitant to restart the campaign what's
more there are three tiers of mayhem
mode with the second and third offering
better rewards for tougher fights and
more random challenges gearbox does need
to do some balancing with these tiers
but the fact that they exist and offer
an alternative to true vault hunter
tells me that gearbox recognized one of
Borderlands twos few redundancies and
none of the system mentioned proving
grounds which in conjunction with mayhem
mode make for some of the most rewarding
border lancing I've experienced these
six trials act as many dungeons so to
speak offering quick-fire ways to earn
experience and improve
phoo they're also endlessly replayable
and conducive to speedruns so they're a
great place for you to test your endgame
characters but keep improving them in
the process
all these endgame avenues have me
convinced that gearbox did in fact
improve the borderlands formula it just
did so in surprisingly subtle ways it
figured out how best to respect players
time I can't overstate how important
that has become today we have so many
games as service to choose from that
it's actually impossible to see the
breath of everyone more developers are
competing for our time than ever before
we have to carefully consider which
titles will really dig into the concept
of an endgame is so important because
when done well it rewards that loyalty
Bioware's anthem is struggling in large
part because it has not figured this out
warframe a game that's hugely successful
in its own right doesn't really have an
endgame a large number of veteran
players are looking for ways to use
their hard-earned rewards but as of now
they're sort of grasping at straws this
all reminds me of a quote from Moga mu a
youtuber that built his channel largely
around warframe a few years ago he
described the feeling that resonated
with many longtime players he said we're
all dressed up with nowhere to go
water lines 3 is not revolutionary in
large part it gives Borderlands fans
more of what they want and that's
completely fine it's not what I was
really hoping for but it's what I
expected and it makes sense but I wasn't
expecting to find so much depth in
Borderlands threes end game it shows to
me that gearbox did in some way want to
tweak the larger Borderlands formula it
knows the value of respecting dedicated
players time and it's here in its later
hours when it shows it's real worth it
tells you to dress up yes but then it
gives you somewhere to go